[Music]
foreign
so I'm pretty excited we are starting to
get into my favorite material and
differential equations which is
specifically how we can relate
differential equations and linear
algebra so in the last few pictures
we've been talking about these higher
order ordinary differential equations
what I mean by high order is that we
have many many derivatives of our state
x with respect to time so not just first
derivatives x dot or second derivatives
X double dot but nth derivatives
um you know in this notation here and
today what I'm going to show you is how
to turn this high order ode with a lot
of derivatives
into a coupled system of first order
Odes so specifically we're going to turn
this into a system
a system of coupled
first order
first order
Odes
and what I mean by first order is this
is going to be a system of n coupled
first order Odes where each of those
equations each of those Odes is only
going to have first derivatives with
respect to time so this might be easier
I'm going to show you in fact it is a
lot easier to solve these systems of
coupled first order Odes than their
equivalent higher order representation
these are totally equivalent but this is
where we usually like to work
computationally on computers even pencil
and paper everything is easier here I'm
just going to jump in this is an
important lecture so pay attention and
then the next few we're going to start
talking about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors some of my absolute
favorite material in all of Applied math
I think you're going to love it okay so
what we're trying to do
is take this high order system and write
it as a matrix system of first order
equations and we can do that pretty
simply by introducing new variables so
we introduce uh introduce
new variables
So currently the only variable we have
here is X and now we're going to
introduce some new variables and I
actually opened up a new pack of markers
because I'm so excited about this
lecture and so we're going to say our
first variable is just our original
state X
our second variable is going to be x dot
the first derivative of x
x 3 is going to be X double dot you see
the pattern here all the way down I'm
going to have n of these variables so I
have an nth order differential equation
and so I'm going to write this in terms
of n coupled first order equations in
these new variables where my last one
is the n minus oneth derivative the N
minus oneth derivative okay so this is
my my new state Vector that I'm going to
be dealing with is this X1 through xn
where each state in this Vector is
represents the the state my original
variable X and all of its derivatives up
to n minus 1.
and so specifically I can write down a
pretty simple differential equation or
system of differential equations so what
we're going to write down
is of course X
1 Dot
X1 dot is literally just x dot
and x dot is X2 so we say X1 dot equals
X2 let's I'm going to repeat this one
time very important we're going to take
the DDT of each of these of each of
these variables we're going to figure
out what
x1.x2.x3.r and then we're going to
represent those in terms of X1 X2 X3 and
so on and so forth we want a closed form
system of the derivatives of all of
these states as a linear combination of
those n States so I start with X1 and I
compute X1 dot X1 dot is the time
derivative of x
you know xdot which is my second state
X2 so X1 dot equals X2
similarly X2 Dot
if I have X2 dot that's x dot dot or X
double dot which is my state X3
and so on and so forth so x k is going
to be the D DT of x k is going to be x k
plus 1. and that works all the way for
all of these rows until the very last
one so uh let's say x 3 dot is going to
be X double dot another dot so the D DT
of this of this x double dot is now x
triple dot which is going to be my X4
state so X4 and so on and so forth until
this very last row equation where now
I'm going to have x n Dot
the time derivative of this state is the
time derivative of this and if we add
one more derivative to the N minus 1
derivative we get the X to the nth
derivative this equals uh you know the
nth derivative of x
which is
specifically
um
can I just make my life easier for one
moment please bear with me I'm going to
divide all of these coefficients by a n
that's totally fine because I can divide
all of my coefficients by a n and these
are just new coefficients and it still
equals zero I'm going to get rid of that
here real quick and so now when I'm
trying to do this last row equation x n
dot which is the nth derivative it
equals all of this stuff moved over to
the right hand side the nth derivative
equals minus all of this stuff here so
this literally equals
this equals
[Music]
I'm just going to do it it's a
minus
all of this stuff minus a not X
minus
A1
so X is just X1 so minus a naught X1
minus A1 x dot which is X which is X2
minus A1 X 2.
minus a
two
second derivative is X3
I just want to be very careful minus dot
dot dot dot minus
a n minus 1
times the N minus 1 derivative which is
my x n
okay I think
this is correct I'm going to just look
at my notes it looks like I got it right
and there's minuses on all of these
okay so I'm not completely convinced
that at this point maybe you shouldn't
be completely convinced at this point
that I've actually done anything to
simplify my system but very soon I will
hopefully convince you that this is
actually much much easier uh to work
with
so what I'm going to do now and I think
I'll switch to uh to Blue here is now
what we're going to do is we're going to
be able to write this
all this whole system of equations I
want to make sure I have enough space
here
um
I can write this as DDT
of my vector
X1 X 2 X 3 dot dot dot all the way to x
n
this is going to be a big Matrix
times my vector
X1 X2 X3 all the way to xn so it's going
to be some big Matrix and I want to make
sure to give myself space here so I'll
go all the way up to the end
a big Matrix times
x 1 x 2 x 3 dot dot dot
xn okay and I don't want to be sloppy
here
x n
okay and so this is really easy to read
off what the terms of this big Matrix
are X1 dot equals X2 so that is 0 1 0
dot dot dot
you know what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to add one more
um
one more row should I add one more Row
for the X N minus one I think I'm going
to I think you're going to thank me
later if I had one more row
for x n minus one I'll make this a
little bit more concise so X
n minus 1 x n
okay this is going to go down to X
n minus one
to X N good
and now this big Matrix here okay so the
X1 dot term is X2 which if I take this
and I multiply it over this is kind of
the uh you know the X1 spot the X2 spot
the X3 spot dot dot dot x n minus one
spot X and spot If I multiply this whole
thing over so X1 dot equals X2 so that's
0 1 0 dot dot dot zero zero easy easy
easy X2 dot is X3 so similarly that is
zero zero one dot dot dot zeros
everywhere else the X3 dot is X4 which
is you know zero zero zero the next
column would have a one in it but I
don't have it written here dot dot dot
zero zero
okay
it's just not mess anything up here
and now the X and minus oneth derivative
D DT of this is X N so I'm going to have
zeros everywhere here up until the very
last entry so DDT of x n minus 1 should
be x n and that is in fact what I get if
I multiply this so so far most of this
Matrix is almost trivial it's mostly
zeros and it has one diagonal of ones
saying that X1 dot equals X2 X2 dot
equals X3 X3 dot equals X4 dot dot dot x
n minus 1 dot equals x n and all of the
action all of the interesting you know
stuff in this differential equation all
these coefficients enter in this last
equation so this x n Dot
is minus
a0 and the X1
minus A1 X2
minus A3
no A2 sorry I really should be careful
here minus A2 times X3
dot dot dot dot
minus uh a
n minus one
yeah minus uh
a n minus 2 times x n minus 1 and minus
a n minus 1. times x n so you can kind
of convince yourself just go through the
motions you know take this Vector knock
it on its side multiply it by this and
convince yourself that that's equal to
this equation here and in fact all of
these equations are represented by this
Matrix system of equations
so now this is actually something that
we can really work with this is a linear
algebra we can I'm going to show you in
the next few lectures we can solve this
system in closed form by finding the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this
Matrix we can integrate this numerically
way way easier than working with this
object here finding
even if I wanted to find the the
characteristic the roots of the
characteristic polynomial the best way
to do that is to find the eigenvalues of
this a matrix which I'll show you in a
minute
so I'll just write this and kind of
summarize this whole thing here
you can write as a big Vector X this is
you know I'm going to use the notation
that an under bar means that this is a
big Vector of States X this is literally
um
under bar x equals you know x 1 x 2 x 3
dot dot dot x n minus 1 x n
that's what this under bar means and so
this x Vector dot is equal to this big a
matrix this big a matrix
times x so this is a matrix system of
equations they are coupled because X1
depends on x2 and X2 depends on X3 and
dot dot and xn depends on all of them so
it's coupled it's coupled there are n
coupled first order equations because
I'm only taking a single time derivative
of any of these states
now of course morally we know that these
states represent higher derivatives of
my original variable X but here we have
transformed the system so it's simpler
so I'm only dealing with first
derivatives of a larger dimensional a
larger State X you know under bar that
has n components this is a vector this
is a matrix a and this is another Vector
so this is a huge deal this
um
we are going to spend most uh of the
next I would say four uh lectures maybe
five or six lectures now dealing with
this Matrix system of equations because
this is where linear algebra and
differential equations meet so this is
where uh you know linear algebra
linear algebra
and differential equations diff EQ
this is where they meet and it is
wonderful okay so this Matrix system of
equations is where we're going to use
all of our powerful techniques from
linear algebra to solve really really
interesting systems in differential
equations and for me this is the high
water mark uh you know of Applied math
really is when we start analyzing these
systems and understanding the real world
in terms of both linear algebra and
differential equations
okay good
[Music]
um
that's the main thing I wanted to show
you is how you can take any higher order
system and turn it into a coupled system
of first order equations which gives you
this Matrix system of equations
what I think I'm going to show you for
the rest of this lecture because I do
have a little bit of time is the next
thing I'm going to show you this is very
important is
that the eigenvalues the eigenvalues
of a this a matrix
are the roots of the characteristic
polynomials are their roots
of the characteristic polynomial
and these mean the same thing
essentially uh I've I've shown you
before that this is true polynomial
sorry it got got cut off
these are the roots of the
characteristic polynomial let's just
call it poly for short we're friends
uh polypolynomial
and I've shown you this for a second
order system before and so now I'm just
going to you know again convince you
that the eigenvalues of this a matrix
are equivalent to the roots of this
characteristic polynomial okay so I can
kind of my eigenvalue equation for how I
solve for the eigenvalues of a that
eigenvalue equation is my characteristic
polynomial I'm going to erase this and
I'm going to show you that just stay put
okay so we have shown how you take this
system and sorry this high order ode and
turn it into a system of first order
Odes and I claim that the characteristic
polynomial of this equation
is
um the same as the eigenvalue equation
for this a matrix this big Matrix here
that relates all of these these states
[Music]
and specifically the eigenvalue equation
the equation you use to find the
eigenvalues of a so the
um let's I'm just going to use for short
we call these the IGS sometimes the
eigenvalues the IGS of a are
specifically those lambdas are
landas
that satisfy
this equation determinant
of a minus Lambda times the identity
Matrix equals zero now I'm going to
derive this from scratch in a couple of
lectures very soon specifically as a set
of lambdas that you need to solve this
differential equation to solve this
differential equation so
if this looks like a bunch of hairy math
that came out of nowhere it is but I'm
going to derive this in a little bit
just take for Grand granted not Granite
take for granted uh just for the moment
that this is the expression that you use
to solve for eigenvalues of a okay this
is how you find the eigenvalues of a is
you find the lambdas so that the
determinant of this Matrix equals zero
okay
on an example
um
so the example I'm going to do is let's
say example
is I'm just going to do this up to third
order so I'm going to say I have DDT
of
X1 X2 X3
and we know that this is going to be 0 1
0 0 0 1 and then minus
a naught minus
A1 minus A2
times X1 x 2 and x 3. and of course this
is
um
the The Matrix system representation of
a third order ode that I'll write out
here so this third order ode would be
um x triple Dot
plus
um
I guess A2 X double dot plus a 1 x dot
plus a zero x equals zero so I hope you
believe and have been convinced that
this equation in green and this system
in blue are completely equivalent this
is just what happens when you suspend
variables and write this as a coupled
system of first order equations and so I
claim that the characteristic polynomial
of this ordinary differential equation
of third order is the same as the
eigenvalue equation for this system the
equivalent system of first order okay
and so I'm actually going to take this
blue equation and I'm literally going to
compute this is my a matrix here this
this thing
here is my a matrix so I'm literally
going to compute a minus Lambda I
a minus Lambda times the identity Matrix
is this Matrix
literally this Matrix minus an identity
Matrix just has diagonals of one so
maybe I'll write down here you know
Lambda I
equals minus lambda zero zero zero minus
lambda zero zero zero minus Lambda it's
literally a diagonal matrix of of plus
lambdas these are Plus
just a diagonal man Matrix of lambdas
because the identity Matrix is diagonal
of ones If I multiply it by a constant
Lambda it's diagonal of lambdas so a
minus Lambda I is this a matrix minus
this Matrix and so that's minus Lambda 1
0.
0 minus Lambda 1.
minus a0
minus A1
minus Lambda minus a 2.
okay that's not too bad and now I need
to take the determinant of this kind of
ugly expression here maybe I'll switch
colors to Orange just to keep things
interesting so the determinant
of a minus Lambda I
now Computing the determinant of a big
Matrix is kind of nasty it's like a
combinatorially complex calculation but
for a three by three matrix it's easy
I'm hoping you remember from you know
high school that it's basically this
term times the DI this element times the
determinant of this little two by two
sub block minus this element times the
determinant of the two by two subblock
omitting that row and column
plus this element times the determinant
of this little two by two sub block so
we can do this easily it's minus Lambda
times this determinant which is a Lambda
squared plus a 2 Lambda minus minus A1
which is plus A1 I'm really hoping I
don't botch this okay that's the first
term
minus
1 times the determinant of this 2 by 2
Sub block so these two multiplied
together minus these two multiplied
together and that's
plus 0
minus minus a0 is Plus
a zero and then we also have to add zero
times the determinant of this sub block
but that's just zero so plus zero okay
so that's all the terms for the
determinant and if I didn't mess up that
equals
everything has a minus sign so I'm just
going to say minus
Lambda cubed
plus A2 Lambda squared plus A1 Lambda I
already pulled the minus out so plus a 0
all of that and this determinant has to
equal zero that's the condition
determinant of a minus Lambda I has to
equal zero for Lambda to be an
eigenvalue of a
so this is literally the equation for
lambdas that are eigenvalues of this a
matrix
but you'll notice that this is also
exactly the equation for the
characteristic polynomial of this
differential equation I'll just write it
out Lambda cubed plus A2 Lambda squared
plus A1 Lambda plus a0 equals zero
so this is the eigenvalue equation
the eigenvalue equation
for
a
and the characteristic polynomial for
this differential equation is very
similarly
Lambda cubed plus you can read it off
plus A2 Lambda squared plus A1 Lambda
plus a zero equals zero this is the
characteristic polynomial
characteristic poly and of course these
two are completely equal to each other
so that's what I wanted to show you is
that yes in fact
the roots of the characteristic
polynomial are in fact eigenvalues of
this Matrix a I can find the eigenvalues
of a and that gives me the roots of my
characteristic polynomial I can find the
roots of my characteristic polynomial
those will give me the eigenvalues of a
and of course we know that this
characteristic polynomial is useful
because it tells me specifically the
lambdas that give me admissible
Solutions X of T equals e to the Lambda
T so that's going to be a solution of
this differential equation if Lambda
satisfies this characteristic polynomial
or if Lambda is an eigenvalue of my a
matrix very very useful very very simple
so we're going to come back in force
looking at this system of equations what
are the eigenvalues of a what are the
eigenvectors of a mean how do we compute
them how do we solve this system using
this math this is kind of my favorite
topic and I'm very excited to walk you
through it so stay tuned for more thank
you
[Music]